it seems to me the world is getting
better and better and better and better
people are living longer people are more
prosperous yet there's this like fake
narrative that we're all gonna die soon
yeah so extrapolate okay so so let's get
a few statistics
um
for as far back as we can tell people
earned uh two dollars per person per day
or less that was that was that was a
global average or or the or the
productive equivalent thereof about two
dollars per person per day today
globally uh average daily income is
forty dollars per person per day okay
and so it went from two to forty in how
long uh well
in the last 200 years okay and until
about 1800 the the world income was
Industrial Revolution pretty much pretty
much stagnant at two dollars person per
day you can take it back 2 000 years ago
or ten thousand years ago it would still
be the same in the last 200 years and
that's a global average obviously in the
United States we have much richer our
income per day is something like 180
dollars per person per day on average
again
um so again in 1800 90 of people live on
two dollars per person per day or less
um uh
um today it's down to about eight or
nine percent
uh as late as 1900 so the presidency of
Theodore Roosevelt in the richest
countries in the world life expectancy
was 50 years
today around the world it's uh 72 years
in the United States it's 78 years and
in some countries it's even even higher
um roughly half of babies who were born
died in infancy before the age of one or
before the age of five half of all
babies would die up to half and that was
it that was in what year well uh 1700s
1700s in in Sweden for example we have
very good records for Sweden so the
between one third and a half but there
could be years in which half of newborns
and what's that number today around the
world globally well uh in in in in the
most developed countries it would be in
low single digits uh let's say around
two to five percent now
that's not just because of lack of care
I mean you know kids come into the world
with all sorts of
um you know some kids with all sorts of
defects and they die unfortunately but
but it's much much lower
um
so so that was that was the world before
and I think that part of the reason for
this uh tremendous amount of negativity
about the future of America in the
western civilization it's not just this
green apocalypse that we have been told
about every day but also that nobody is
singing the Praises of the American
experiment or the Western experiment
overall uh right now in the United
States we don't really have a
constituency
praising
um president of the United States I'll
tell you why it may be counter-intuitive
but I think you see when you have a
republican in charge all the Democrats
say the world is going to end this is
the worst thing that could have happened
he's the new Hitler but the same thing
oddly enough happens when you have a
democrat in charge is that Republicans
say the country is in permanent decline
look at this Joker in charge you know
he's obviously senile country has never
been worse off so the point is that that
in order to get people excited about
voting is to piss them off is to make
them angry and the only way you can do
it is by saying everything is going to
hell and both parties do that nobody is
saying that the country is doing well
ever ever is that unique to America or
is that just a political agenda on all
countries
I'm most familiar with the United States
and this political polarization where
you cannot admit that the other party is
doing even one percent right right that
that I think is specifically unique to
us right
um the other things that are happening
of course you've got the rise of the CRT
and attacks on on free speech and and
part of the critical race Theory
business is that is that it attacks the
founding of the United States America is
very different from Western Europe or
from Europe where I'm from in the united
in in in Western Europe or in Europe in
order to become a member of the tribe so
to speak you have to be born into that
Nation you have to be born check or you
have to be born Slovak or you have to be
born German to be properly understood as
that but in the United States we don't
work like that we have our constitution
right we do not have kings queens we
don't even have that longer history but
we do have the Constitution
um and the founding documents and the
founding fathers and right now in the
United States what we are seeing is a
concentrated attack on everything that
until two seconds ago was considered to
be somewhat sacred which is to say the
founding and the revolution
1619 project versus the 1776 project is
a perfect example of that
so
so you basically no longer if people ask
you well then what was the good part of
of America you cannot actually say
because in every part of of our American
history there has always been somebody
who was not doing terribly well or
somebody who was discriminated against
or whatever so on that basis
we can really no longer say that
anything in America works because it is
Tainted by uh by this by this history
that the CRT put at the center of its
philosophy hmm uh are you saying that
you're not willing to make America great
again
I
I'm saying that America was great is
great and can be even greater I love
that uh
this lack of patriotism right I think
something an issue that I have with the
Democratic side of the aisle is if you
see a flag
over someone's house yes or on their
bumper sticker or someone wearing a a an
American flag hat yes what political
party would you most likely affiliate
you assume they are Republican because
you would assume they're Republican yeah
because they have an American flag that
to me is ludicrous and and because
there's a there seems to be a large
contingency on the left the far left who
genuinely hates
the concept of America the 1619 project
my point would be the only way you can
hate America is the is if if the if your
diet of news or whatever you are reading
or learning only focuses on the bad
things in American history but of course
every country in the world has some sort
of a terrible past every every
civilization in world history had
slavery for example I mean this is a
topic that Americans talk about more
than anything else and uh the reality is
that it's always been there and until
200 years ago it never occurred to
anybody that you could have there was
not a sustained movement anywhere in the
world for the abolishment of slavery
until Britain in seven in late 1700s so
I I think it is quite wrong to uh to to
focus just on that as opposed to all the
all the good things that America has
done including providing very high
standards of living for the people of of
all colors and immigrants and immigrants
but you have to agree though that
Anti-Flag American settlement I did not
see it until six years ago as a veteran
as a proud American as you know my whole
family served in the military pants a
veteran I didn't start seeing that at
all ever until Trump was in and the flag
in America they were they had to do the
opposite of whatever Trump was saying
and that's where that started that
looking at flag that that what do you
what do you proud what are you so proud
of We Come From Slavery and we're this
country is and that's why all those
gens whatever it was a disease they've
been bombarded with hey this country
hates you we come from and no no
it's not great no doubt a large part of
it was Trump I think it was in Prior
with Obama but I mean a lot of it
started with bush too if you believe the
future looks bright order your future
looks bright hat today
[Music]